Lonely Planet travel writer Katharina Kane is in Ethiopia.
She's heading outside Harar's ancient city walls to see a man who's famous for feeding hyenas.
I've never heard of anybody attempting to feed hyenas, it just seems a little crazy.
Why would you do that?
You know, aren't they scavengers and they're supposed to like eat dead meat?
So, obviously I want to see this.
The story goes that hyena feeding began 50 years ago...
...to keep them from entering the city walls.
Now it becomes a tourist attraction for a lot of Ethiopians.
I get the impression that they're his friends, he's calling them by name.
Amalis was just saying to me that they're so tame, they just walk through town sometimes, right?
Is that right?
I always thought hyenas were like, you know, the ugliest creatures that actually existed,...
...but when you're sitting up close, they're actually strangely beautiful.
Come on, come on, come on.